[Music]
lots of people are very excited about
tonight's Powerball lottery drawing you
know what it's up to now 500 million
dollar jackpot 500 million dollar
jackpot yeah
now let's face it the odds of actually
winning at Powerball pretty astronomical
okay but we just learned there's a new
lottery game that gives all of us much
better odds at winning this is very
exciting take a look are you tired of
buying lottery tickets and winning
absolutely nothing how'd you like a
lottery game that guarantees you win
every time introducing three four five
for every $5 ticket you buy you're
guaranteed to win three dollars all I
have to do is buy one $5.00 ticket and
you'll win three dollars every time but
what if I bought two $5.00 tickets then
you'd win six dollars I could get used
to this
you sure can just take it from this
three four five jackpot winner I've
complained three to five for about a
year now and uh look what I bought with
my winnings this photo of a boat
and now for you high rollers try four
four six new from the California
[Applause]
you